get ready for the Justice League to
perform big-time at the box office it's
already projected to rake in between 110
and 120 million dollars opening weekend
alone Carly still sat down with a cast
including Aquaman Jason Momoa who had
quite the costume confession if you guys
could tweak one thing about your costume
what would it be
I'd probably make the codpiece a little
smaller it just took away the attention
from everything else you can definitely
catch been just over what you like just
lock onto a buddy I know call it justice
league on censored this cast got super
tight spending 25 weeks shooting on
location together but there's always the
secret or two like which superhero got
his own hot tub did everyone get to
partake in the hot tub it was just no
one in the movie Batman Wonder Woman and
the rest of the Justice League band
together to battle an ax-wielding
supervillain at off-screen well there
was some banding together there too when
is the album being released because it
looked like you guys had started a band
from Jason's trailer music session the
gym the movie is actually a trailer to
the Batman
van you jammed I tap that's aborting you
kept the beat
[Music]
you